[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de 7,8 culture le sommaire de ce
mardi 19 mars entre shakespeare et walt
disney deux adolescents se cherche et
jouent au jeu de l'amour une création de
la compagnie larousse qui associe des
lycéens de la plaine de notre le tout
sur les planches de la merise nous
reviendrons sur cette aventure avec nos
invités de la romance il en sera aussi
question en livre nous nous sommes
rendus au salon du livre de paris grand
rendez-vous du monde derrière les
petites maisons d'édition ayant eux
aussi leur place nous avons suivi
photo fly édition de thouaré l'ombre
d'un court le festival de courts
métrages de jouy en josas est 10 en une
édition anniversaire avec le jury et
ciel nous reviendrons sur son programme
le salon du livre de paris se dérouler
tout le week-end dans les salles
d'expositions de la porte de versailles
il s'est achevée lundi avec la journée
réservée aux professionnels de la
littérature 391 stands d'exposants et
par me bopda fly édition une petite
maison d'édition de thoiry reportage
dans leur univers du livre romance le
salon du livre de paris c'est plus de
160 mille visiteurs 3900 hauteur pour
lesquels il faut parfois se montrer
patient pour avoir une dédicace et de
grands noms de l'édition par milieu des
petites maisons compte bien profiter de
l'événement pour se faire connaître
arrêt au stand eu 57 c'est notre
troisième année une version salon du
livre
on a commencé en 2000
16 avec un
2017 avec un petit stand coup de pouce
c'est les tout petits stands pour les
éditeurs débutants ou les portois les
auteurs autoédités et l'année dernière
on a pris un stand qui ressemblait à
celui ci un sens dans les pistes année
on a réitéré l'expérience butterfly
édition est né en 2016 à thoiry sa
spécialisation la romance un genre
littéraire qui conquis son public
surtout en version numérique
c'est l'occasion pour eux de rencontrer
nos livres papier de discuter avec les
auteurs d'échangé on se rende compte que
des deux côtés auteurs ou aux lecteurs
c'est formidable pour eux quatre mois de
préparation pour réussir à faire venir
une vingtaine d'auteurs en dédicace un
week-end intense
alors en ce dernier jour consacré aux
professionnels on en profite pour faire
des rencontres à rien et chroniqueurs
spécialisés dans la romance elle a
justement fait la critique de l'un des
romans de butterfly édition c'est vrai
que c'est un microcosme
très particulier dans la littérature
l'art annonce et c'est un plaisir de
pouvoir rencontrer les gens avec qui on
communique toute l'année
par mail ou pour les différents services
presse donc c'est l'occasion pour nous
de pouvoir rencontrer tout le monde en
étant sur sa longue et de paris d'après
le centre national du livre 92% des
français se déclarent lecteurs en 2019
en poche ou sous format numérique le
livre est encore prêt à nous faire vivre
de nombreuses histoires dans le cas de
la semaine d'égalité femmes hommes de
plaisir le conservatoire organisé un
atelier danse père enfant samedi 26 mars
patrick jacques de dixmude s'y est rendu
ce matin là au conservatoire de plaisir
les enfants font danser leur papa
moi qui fais souvent des stages par
enfant la plupart du temps c'est les
mères qui viennent avec leurs enfants et
aujourd'hui on a bien signalé que c'est
un atelier papa enfants la danseuse
chorégraphe venue de poitiers a préparé
toute une série de jeux pour que les
deux opus vivre de vrais moments de
partage artistique
on va pas se mettre à la barre et faire
des exercices dit de danse
en fait on va rentrer en mouvement de
façon ludique joyeuse dans le jeu ils
vont pas avoir l'impression de se mettre
dedans c'est finalement à la fin
la séance est pour sa part se voir
qu'ils sont en danse et qui sont bien
dans leur corps en train de danser avec
les corps qu'ils ont même s'ils ne sont
pas danseur à la base allez on va faire
de ce jeu là vous avez décidé entre vous
qui est sédentaire qui est nomade
une matinée qui s'inscrit dans la
semaine pour l'égalité femmes hommes de
la ville de plaisir
histoire de rappeler que les papas aussi
peuvent passer du temps avec leurs
enfants
toute la semaine on est au boulot on
travaille et nos enfants font les
activités à côté et donc là c'est un
moment privilégié où je vois voir ce
qu'elle fait et puis elle ça lui plaît
aussi de savoir que son papa viens et
vois ce qu'elle fait et partager des
moments avec elle
c'est vrai qu'à la maison à loulans
souvent pour pour la campagne qu'on
danse avec elle un peu à la maison donc
là c'était l'occasion de faire ça dans
un endroit avec un cadre avec une
professionnelle donc voilà c'est
l'occasion de le partager ce moment
ensemble pendant un peu à la maison avec
elle enfin on peut les foufous et puis
avec danse avec les stars
on s'y prête donc c'est l'occasion de
faire ça ici avec avec des papas qui
font les fous fous avec leur petite
fille liz et petit garçon une matinée
riche en complicité
attention cet atelier père enfant et
réalisés par des amateurs
il est fortement recommandé de le
reproduire chez soi
[Musique]
new york new york fly me to the moon ses
chansons dépasse les frontières et les
époques celle d'une icône frank sinatra
pierre henry gates et la troupe en
chantier lui rendent hommage sur scène
avec un spectacle musical de près de
deux heures pour raconter l'homme
derrière le mythe 35 musiciens de
l'harmonie monique oise l'accompagnent
ce samedi 23 mars à la salle de la voa
versailles 24 chansons redécouvrir
extrême un classique
[Musique]
cette mission
super u le mot
et n'a donc oui
[Musique]
et nous on adore
je fais
qu'est ce
et vous pourrez également retrouver le
spectacle au mois de mai pendant le
versailles jazz festival depuis le mois
de janvier la compagnie larousse est en
résidence entre la merise et le lycée de
la plaine de neauphle attrape pour ce
spectacle spécimens qui parle de
l'adolescence les lycéens étaient
invités à rentrer dans le processus de
création avec nous en plateau mêlant
perrinelle vous êtes chargé du projet de
la compagnie in green cove qui
directrice adjointe de la mairie et
marwa zaghdane scène de la plaine de nos
offres intégrées au projet bonsoir à
tout les 3 monts française alors
spécimens c'est un texte écrit par
nathalie d'un sar il s'inspire de
réflexion à des échanges qu'elle a pu
avoir avec désolé d'adolescents lors
d'ateliers le spectacle est créé à la
merise avec des lycéens milly perrin
pouvez vous nous expliquer un peu la
démarche
oui bien sûr alors c'est un spectacle
effectivement dont le projet a vraiment
débuter en 2014 dans une résidence à
pontault combault dans un lycée où la
compagnie a pu travailler en fait là bas
avec des adolescents dans le cadre
d'ateliers et s'est rendu compte que les
sujets finalement qui intéressait les
adolescents outre les sujets de société
etc
ça tournait beaucoup autour de choses
qui leur paraissent très tabou et qui à
la fois les attire beaucoup c'est à dire
l'amour les sentiments les choses un peu
intime et du coup c'était sur ces sujets
là que la metteuse en scène nathalie
bansard avait envie de travailler et du
coup ça l'a conduit à l'écriture de la
pièce spécimens qui est une pièce pour
deux comédiens qu'on va avoir la chance
de créer jeudi en plus en collaboration
avec la classe des secondes 6 donc
justement c'est une collaboration entre
une salle de spectacle la merise une
compagnie donc la compagnie larousse et
un lycée le lycée de la plaine de noves
comment tout ça s'est mis en place une
grille alors en fait le la halle
culturel la merise et en partenariat
depuis de nombreuses années avec le
lycée de la plaine de neauphle il ya
notamment l'option facultative théâtre
que nous présentons tous les ans sur le
plateau de la merise en fin d'année
nathalie bessard elle donc a été
accueillie avec la compagnie larousse à
plusieurs reprises dans le cadre de la
programmation
nous avons eu la princesse au petit pois
il ya quelques années amy qui est à 10
la saison dernière donc quand nathalie
m'a présenté son projet sur la
thématique des adolescents et des
histoires d'amour l'idée est venue de
faire une résidence territoriale
artistique et culturelle en milieu
scolaire donc c'est un dispositif
financé par la drac ile-de-france et le
projet a été présenté à la proviseur et
aux enseignants du lycée qui sont partis
dans l'aventuré avec nous donc voilà
pendant plusieurs mois il y à des
actions culturelles et les élèves
participent de différentes manières que
ce soit au niveau du travail de costumes
au niveau de la prise de son autour de
la création du spectacle et ils font
aussi des retours sur ce qu'il voit et
sur les présentations qui sont faites
par la compagnie alors justement parmi
ses élèves il ya marois vous avez
participé août à tout le processus
ce que vous venez d'écrire un peu cette
expérience qu'est ce que vous avez fait
alors tout d'abord on n'est pas reçue à
la mairie pour pour pour que prix nous
présente le projet la pièce de théâtre
on a fait beaucoup beaucoup d'ateliers
avec eux entre premier on a fait des
pièces de théâtre par rapport à roméo et
juliette ensuite ils sont venus chez
nous au lycée on a fait plusieurs
séances au lycée on à fait différent
différentes différentes choses
par rapport avec les costumes de son et
je crois que vous avez aussi travaillé
sur une chorégraphie on va certainement
la voir s'afficher à l'écran c'est le
teaser un peu de spectacle ça cette
chorégraphie vous classez les comédiens
qu'on va voir cette comédie où là vous
allez la reproduire sur scène je dis oui
avec toute la classe
oui à la fin de la pièce donc vous
l'avez créer avec eux ou vous a entraîné
à la ferme nous montrer la vidéo et
petit à petit il nous apprenait l'est
pas enfin de la chorégraphie et après on
a appris en deux jours est maintenant
dans le camp des repas tous les jours
donc la thématique de la pièce on y
revient c'est l'adolescence et
l'appréhension de l'amour dans cette
phase un peu transitoire il ya deux
personnages qui se posent des questions
lens représente l'amour à la william
shakespeare l'autre est plutôt à walt
disney en fait il ya aussi trouver un
travail sur les stéréotypes qui ont été
pensés oui exactement parce que
effectivement la pièce c'est un garçon
et une fille un garçon qui emmène la
fille dans un théâtre lui fait son club
théâtre et où il a peut-être envie un
petit peu de l'impressionner et
finalement une des conversations mais
qu'on a eus y compris avec les élèves et
du coup voilà on s'est aussi inspiré de
leur réflexion à eux de leur point de
vue de leur retour tournait beaucoup
autour de garçons filles qu'est ce que
c'est c'est quoi les préjugés autour de
ça c'est quoi les stéréotypes autour de
ça et comment quand on est dans cette
période un petit peu étrange à la sortie
de l'enfance est pas encore tout à fait
à l'âge adulte et qu'on est un peu sur
le terrain de la séduction
comment ces stéréotypes nous bloque nous
retiennent ce genre de choses et donc
marois vous avez pu lire le texte c'est
leur faire un retour et la compagnie sur
ce texte
non ils nous ont fait la pièce de
théâtre l'on jouait devant nous et vu
que on n'osait pas trop dire ce qu'on
pense et de la pièce on a écrit des
petits papiers anonymes et les ont vus
et on en a discuté et voilà donc là on
voit un peu tout l'intérêt d'associer
des adolescents à cette pièce c'est ça
le principe de ce projet oui exactement
c'est à dire que
vous voulez parler d adolescence au
pluriel bien sûr je pense que les
comédiens louise dupuis et hommes
politiques nos parts aussi beaucoup de
leur adolescence à eux mais c'est sûr
que le projet il aurait pas de sens si
en tout cas il aura un sens différent si
on ne le pensais pas aussi avec des
adolescents avec des gens qui sont en
train de vivre ça à l'heure actuelle de
traverser ça à l'heure actuelle et du
coup c'est ça qui nous emporte est aussi
dans le travail avec cette classe donc
une grille le rendez vous c'est quand
ces jeudis 21 mars à 14 heures il y à
une séance scolaire et à 19 heures donc
la création là tout public donc à la
merise attrape en yvelines donc vous
pouvez noter tout ça sur votre agenda à
la merise attrape sauver qu'elle vous
allez rire à saint quentin en yvelines
pas moins de trois humoristes se rendre
dans différentes salles de
l'agglomération pour leur stand up
interprétation de personnages flash back
musical ou commentaire d'actualité c'est
au choix
montage de jules grenier ville les
adolescents c'est comme les chevaux
c'est toujours mal coiffé sa motion et
céréales et ça ne choque qui sont
l'écurie
françois xavier demaison sans titre
simplement son patronyme pour un
spectacle dans lequel il se raconte plus
que d'habitude
un troisième one man show qui joue
depuis deux ans dans toute la france il
sera vendredi et samedi 22 et 23 mars au
prix smile en cours avant de jouer c'est
toute dernière date à l'olympia mi-avril
les mots serviteur de l'état
une entrée rock'n'roll pour un spectacle
tout en musique pour son numéro 5
christelle chollet a vu les choses en
grand
ce soient les époques on continue
d'inventer des danses à la con souvenez
vous dans les années 70 avait ça
[Musique]
il ya ça
une première en janvier salle pleyel à
paris une tournée en france et en europe
francophone
l'humoriste chante danse et s'éclate sur
scène aux côtés de deux musiciens en
live
vous pouvez la retrouver samedi 23 mars
à la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux salvetois c'est un sketch
héritiers de guy bedos christophe
alévêque revient avec ses feuilles de
notes et son pupitre pour éplucher
l'actualité au sein de son spectacle
revue de presse du breakbeat à la sphère
benalla en passant par les gilet jaune
rien n'échappe aux remarques cinglantes
de l'humoriste mais faut les comprendre
la violence voilà on dit ouais il votre
recueil les trucs de violence bon c'est
quand même plus excitant t-il mais des
bagarres des feux de voitures des
vitrines au cassis que les gens mal
habillés qui défilent sans rien faire si
chacune partie curling
il sera samedi 23 mars à l'espace albert
camus à maurepas pour vous prendront
complices de ces réflexions
humoristiques pendant près de deux
heures
depuis vendredi 15 mars et jusqu'au
dimanche 7 avril c'est la 17e édition du
festival à tout bout de champ à magny
les hameaux en rendez vous culturel sous
toutes ses formes et pour tous les
publics au sein de la maison de
l'environnement pouvait retrouver une
exposition originale un illustrateur et
créateurs d'albums pour enfants s'est
entouré de dix classes classe manu coise
de la petite section de maternelle au
cm2 pour que les enfants écrivent
illustrer l hymne leur jardin imaginaire
michael el fathi a répondu aux questions
de mélanie poquet j'ai travaillé avec
mon chapeau à chaque coup dans lequel je
notais en fait des propositions de deux
scénarios des enfants en les guidant un
petit peu on puis en leur rappelant
toujours donc le thème du jardin vauban
mais ils ont joué un jeu assez
facilement donc concrètement je leur
demandais de me donner un lieu le parage
principal le méchant de l'histoire
et puis eux sensibles rôdait autour de
ça dans le cadre de ce même festival un
spectacle pour expliqué serge gainsbourg
aux enfants ce samedi 23 mars à 15
heures à la maison de l'environnement
deux classes des écoles rosa bonheur et
andré gide a sûrement
la première partie en interprétant trois
chansons du répertoire de l'homme à la
tête de chou sur le mur y'a marqué chi
barbe pas au toit je suis là pour te
protéger je ferme les yeux
en principe ce mois ci par là
[Musique]
du cinéma à présent avec le festival
international du film court de jouy en
josas par l'association film à venir une
édition spéciale car le festival fête
ses dix ans avec nous en plateau
franceville est
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes le
directeur du festival une dixième année
pour l'occasion de faire revenir dans le
jury des anciens présidents de jury oui
c'était une idée pour
cette édition un peu spéciale c'est la
dixième édition la deuxième année on a
fait appel à
à des présidents et présidentes qui sont
venues entre 2010 et 2018 donc il y aura
catherine benguigui
il y aurait alexis desseaux gérard de
salles et brigitte le corps d alors le
court métrage c'est souvent un premier
pas pour un jeune réalisateur avant de
se lancer dans le long je pense
notamment à jusqu'à lagarde xavier
legrand qui à la base était un court
métrage qu'il a remporté le césar du lot
cette année donc c'est une sacrée
responsabilité de faire une sélection de
ses courts métrages et de les amener
pour un prix oui c'est une
responsabilité
il y en a beaucoup d'ailleurs qui sont
qui sont passés par le festival l'ombre
d'un cours qui ont soit été nommé aux
césars même aux oscars c'était le cas il
ya deux ans pour le prix du jury garden
party qui a été aux oscars y en a eu
d'autres
ou alors effectivement la possibilité
après de faire un long métrage alors
jusqu'à la gare dont l'apa on l'a pas
sélectionné parce que malheureusement il
fait plus de vingt minutes et nous dans
notre festival c'est 20 minutes de durée
donc on n'a pas eu cette chance là juste
préciser pour le jury puisque j'ai parlé
donc des membres du jury il y aura
évidemment une présidente qui va
chapeauter ce jury il s'agit de dounia
coesens voilà qui a été révélé notamment
par la série plus belle la vie qui fait
maintenant une grande carrière et
beaucoup de téléfilms ou de séries et du
théâtre est donc un jury qui va pouvoir
visionner les films qui a trois cadeaux
catégorie la section ficelles la soirée
l'étranger la section scolaire ça nous
fait combien de films sélectionnés ça
alors il ya trente deux films en
compétition officielle
et une films en compétition scolaire
donc en compétition officielle il ya
également la science de l'étrange avec
la séance de l'étrange alors c'est une
soirée le vendredi à 22h30 qu'on propose
en deux temps il ya tout d'abord une
séquence un peu interactive avec le
public qui consiste à une démonstration
et un concours de maquillage d'effets
spéciaux
donc on peut voir dans les films avec
notre invité spécial qui sera à david
ferrer un spécialiste du genre et puis
ensuite donc c'est un concours il ya
quatre maquilleur qui vont s'affronter
pendant un temps imparti et après il y
aura la désignation du lauréat
ça permet au spectateur de voir un peu
comment ça se passe l'envers du décor
comment se fait un maquillage au cinéma
et notamment pour les films 10 de gens
alors c'est une sélection de films
fantastiques étrange imaginaire horreur
aussi est un thriller voilà c'est une
sorte de patchwork comme ça il ya huit
films en compétition et fiction et
animation justement pour parler de
denvers de décor celui du festival c'est
d'être un temps long travail de
sélection comment vous y prenez c'est un
très long travail de sélection de
présélection de et après de choix
malheureusement il faut faire des choix
c'est toujours très difficile
on en a reçu 1500 cette année il en a
sélectionné 45
parce qu'il ya aussi du hors compétition
et
c'est comment on fait alors on passe par
veut notamment pour le recevoir les
films on passe par une plateforme du
court métrage où les réalisateurs les
productions s'inscrivent et donc comme
ça on peut regarder tous les films et le
choix est très compliqué toujours après
ça reste évidemment subjectif on essaie
d'être au plus juste il ya plusieurs
critères on s'attache au scénario à la
mise en scène à la technique et à
l'interprétation aussi c'est important
c'est un tout et le scénario pour parler
un peu de cette 10e édition
un anniversaire donc forcément il ya des
nouveautés l'udc et une soirée spéciale
en clôture et des ateliers aussi alors
il ya des ateliers le samedi après-midi
oui on vous attend très nombreux
j'espère que les gens vont se
manifester parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
rendez vous il ya des ateliers
cinématographique avec notamment une
exposition de voitures vus au cinéma
c'est les voitures qu'on a vu dans les
films il ya par exemple la une voiture
des gendarmes
la série des gendarmes est assez risqué
à tshela voiture de transformers aussi
un amour de coccinelle entre autres donc
en plus quelle explication et
l'historique de ces voitures par rapport
au film donc c'est l'association rock'n
roll events qui organise ça il ya aussi
un atelier de stop motion qui est un
cinéma d'animation où le public va aussi
pouvoir participer à fabriquer un petit
film et voir le résultat immédiatement
donc c'est très interactif et à 15h30 il
ya une en parallèle donc c'est des
ateliers qui dure toute la journée en
par intermittence
et il ya aussi une compétition
officielle importante le samedi après
midi
notamment parce qu'il ya des pots film
bien sûr mais parce que aussi on reçoit
une équipe d'un film iranien
donc c'est exceptionnel puisque ils se
sont déplacés ils viendront dire en donc
pour présenter leur film c'est un film
sur sur le problème de justice à travers
le monde donc c'est un film assez
important il ya d'autres films et il
faut pas les négliger bien sûr mais il y
aura vraiment une rencontre
exceptionnelle avec cette équipe
iranienne et les autres équipes qui
seront présentes aussi moi c'est une
particularité de cette année là vous
sortez de droite ya même une équipe de
taiwan qui est prévu il ya même une
équipe de taiwan qui vient représenter à
son film ce sera un film pour la séance
scolaire donc ils seront là pour vous
raconter et parler de leurs chine alors
c'est pas la première fois qu'on propose
des films étrangers mais cette année
c'est vraiment
les équipes se sont mobilisés et ont
décidé de venir décote des quatre coins
du monde
on n'oublie pas les les pays les plus
proches c'est un peu facile pour eux de
se déplacer mais faut pas les négliger
non plus il y aura la belgique la suisse
le maroc et le royaume uni qui seront
représentés présent c'est d'où le nom
internationaux internationale qui prend
tout son sens et si je te rappelle la
soirée de clôture vous allez nous on va
nous faire danser sur des musiques de
films on va vous on va vous faire danser
j'espère que ça va me donner envie que
les spectateurs vont avoir envie on
trouve voulait proposer à quelque chose
aussi vraiment pour terminer cette ces
deux jours on voulait proposer quelque
chose de festif et de danse ans donc on
s'est dit comment allier le cinéma la
musique voilà est quelque chose de
dansant donc on a fait appel à un dj dj
prosper que je salue mais voilà et qui
va préparer un mix mêlant des sons
électro disco funk avec des musiques de
films voilà que ce soir entraînant et
bien sûr des musiques assez connu du
grand public company or il va faire un
petit un petit mélange à sa façon voilà
et donc on veut vraiment pour clôturer
proposer cette soirée en plus pour ceux
qui viennent de loin ou de paris je vois
là je leur précise une navette gratuite
qui peuvent les ramener à paris donc il
faut venir à jouy en josas le samedi
après midi et le samedi soir pour cette
soirée de clôture bombard s'il n'avait
il ya pas de raison ils peuvent il n'y a
pas d'inquiétude pour entrer à très long
qu'on donne rendez vous aux cinéphiles
du vendredi 22 au samedi 23 mars vous
pouvez retrouver toute la programmation
sur le site internet de l'association
merci franck pilatte est venu sur notre
plateau merci à vous
reçue alors aperçu de vos autres rendez
vous culturel de la semaine c'est
l'agenda
[Musique]
on commence avec un spectacle de danse
originale des danseurs réunis sur scène
avec des boxeurs les deux chorégraphes
belge koen augustijnen et rosalba torres
guerrero ont mélangé les genres au sein
du spectacle simplement intitulé b 10
danseurs dont trois boxeurs hommes et
femmes à découvrir à l'undd à vélizy ce
samedi 23 mars
pour les plus curieux le spectacle est
précédé d'une conférence sur les
relations entre danse et sport axel une
petite fille de 10 ans rêve de devenir
cosmonaute problème
l'univers est très masculin et elle
peine à trouver sa place cette pièce de
l'embellie compagnie combat les
stéréotypes dans le cadre du temps des
femmes de la ville de guînes en cours
extraits les garçons du club arrive
enfin en bloc
qu'est ce qu'elle fout ici la fille la
pichenette la pisseuse s'aggrave fusil à
pompe et construire des fusées le club
il apprendra à un donjon version
burlesque la compagnie miranda reprend
le célèbre texte de molière et la date
pour une version nez rouge
mise en scène par irina brook à partir
d'un travail de mario gonzalez
une façon de revisiter un classique du
20 au 23 mars au théâtre montansier à
versailles une équipe de cinéma au
théâtre c'est le scénario de silence
qu'on tourne dans cette pièce de comédie
vous êtes figurants et vous assister au
tournage d'une séquence d'un film ou
mise en scène de patrick haudecoeur pour
écrire pendant 1h45 vendredi 22 mars à
l'espace coluche et plaisir artiste
plasticien et curieux se donnent rendez
vous au salon des arts de saint cyr
l'école neuf catégories représentées
dont deux nouvelles le délit painting et
le street art du 20 au 27 mars avec une
nocturne le samedi 23 mars
l'adjointe à la culture de la ville sera
l'invité du 7-8 choisir ce jeudi 21 mars
et c'est la fin de cette édition la
semaine prochaine vous retrouver mélanie
poquet qui reprend la baguette de chef
d'orchestre du 7-8 culture merci nous
avoir suivis et bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]